aujourd'hui, nous sommes ici pour parler de la fusion
combinant deux particules en une
la semaine dernière au Lawrence Livermore
National Laboratory en Californie, les
scientifiques de l'installation nationale d'allumage
ont réalisé l'allumage par fusion
et cela crée plus d'énergie à partir des
réactions de fusion que l'énergie utilisée pour
démarrer le processus
c'est la première fois que cela a été
fait dans un laboratoire
n'importe où dans le monde, c'est
simplement l'un des exploits scientifiques les plus
impressionnants du 21e
siècle,
alors qu'est-ce que cette réalisation fait deux
choses d'abord,
elle renforce notre sécurité nationale
car elle ouvre un nouveau  domaine pour
maintenir une dissuasion nucléaire sûre et efficace
à une époque où
nous n'avons pas d'essais nucléaires, l'
allumage nous permet de reproduire pour la
première fois
certaines conditions que l'on ne trouve que
dans les étoiles et le Soleil
et la deuxième chose qu'il fait bien sûr
est que cette étape importante nous rapproche un peu
plus
de la possibilité d'
une Fusion E abondante sans carbone  l'énergie alimentant notre
société, il y a un petit cylindre ici à
la fin de celui-ci que vous ne pouvez probablement pas
voir, il est à peu près si haut et si large à l'
intérieur qu'il s'agissait d'une petite capsule sphérique
192 faisceaux laser sont entrés par les deux
extrémités du cylindre et ont frappé l'
intérieur  mur, ils n'ont pas frappé la
capsule, ils ont frappé la paroi interne de
ce cylindre
et ont déposé de l'énergie et cela s'est produit
en moins de temps qu'il n'en faut à la lumière pour se déplacer de
10 pieds,
donc c'est une sorte de
rayons X rapides du mur qui ont frappé la
capsule sphérique
Fusion  le carburant dans la capsule a été
comprimé.  produit plus d'
énergies que les lasers n'en avaient déposées